oh my god those look really cool what
looks really cool that's a gradient
uh polka dot pattern yeah also monkey
i have enough crowns to get a monkey
yeah i'm gonna be a monkey
monkey i'm gonna use my crowns to be a
monkey
that's pretty good monkey
oh you are look at you
i'm like a boxer but i have hand lines
put on my monkey fur perfect there's
some fur
[Music]
which one of you is in here right now me
oh yeah i forgot i have to actually
accept the invite
do you like monkey ah they're okay i
guess
hit parade wait you've gotten a win by
now right i've gotten two
oh two i have three wins
wow nice damn pretty pretty good if i
do say so myself was there always ground
was there always like a ground
there are so many monkeys right i
thought it was just
yeah oh that looks oh right
dead oh hey mark do you like mine hey
we're all in this corner
look at this corner mark i'm gonna go
behind you
okay cool and try not to ruin your
business
[Applause]
i fell over what do you mean me yeah why
did you do that you fell over
oh you're right i've forgotten how to
play this game
wait how do you jump and dive i've
controlled as jump axis dive
okay right right right right or square
right right whatever
wait wait wait wait let me you didn't
know okay oh god everything's bad
and i'm unconscious oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god straight up the middle oh yes
oh the winners i will eat your sister's
face coming
[Laughter]
get out of here other monkeys man i miss
when you could tell who the hell your
friends were
uh you can see where i am oh no there's
one other guy there's a lot of monkeys
and there's a lot there's two
two default bros all right now
i won't lose the first second
because every time we've done this one i
died in two seconds
the objective is to stay on top
i'm fine man i'm fine no yeah there
never was this much background was there
no i feel like that's different
yeah it's cool i like it oh
i'm really getting bumped into here oh
dear oh wait wait wait
wait oh yeah
are you alive yeah i'm alive okay good i
escaped hey mark
how's it going hey what's up you know
trying to do this yeah bro stay alive
i feel like there's a lot more gaps in
this than i oh yeah they made more holes
there's bigger gaps they come more
frequently
so terrifying oh i'm following you
wait why would
i like to challenge myself to go end to
end as this level occurs
because it makes it makes it interesting
oh yeah that's what you want
is making things interesting it's so get
off me
oh hey wade you getting dead over here
uh-oh might be in trouble guys
there's nowhere to go might be in
trouble guys oh no made it no you're
good mark you're good
right now apparently hey buddy
what's up oh my god
okay they really cracked up the
difficulty on that one
holy crap holy crap that used to be
nothing that was that used to be you
could like stand still for extended
periods and now it's
good nightmare one person wait what what
what because i counted all the ones
before like 15 people didn't yeah i just
didn't show them fall
oh no oh good tales oh there's there's
more it's multiple fails
just find one and then be be casual
be casual is this teams or just
individuals oh they made more ways to
get up in the middle
i think they made more ways to get up in
the middle did this used to go be like
this
i don't know i got one
no i lost my tail and then i got geeded
like an idiot
you thought you could come hide in the
middle
yeah i think everyone has figured out
the strat of go hide in the middle of
the thing
ow oh no i didn't see that one coming
oh i found a new way to booty casual
very
casual no my tail was taking last second
well there's still 30 seconds you're
still fine okay got it back thank god
all right got my tail back got a tail
back
no what that was some laggy [ __ ]
15 seconds how in the hell
oh god no good thing someone wasn't
paying attention
someone with a tail got slammed into me
so hard that we know
are you kidding me at the last second
you all right mark i'm fine yeah what's
up i uh i also lost
that's okay wait did you get it i didn't
have a tail to like the very end well i
had to tell most the time that it was
stolen then i stole it back
yeah i i had my tail the entire time
and then right at the last second
someone's just like oh hey
boink i really i stole a tail at the
last second i hope that wasn't
yeah you guys were like not paying
attention to each other because you both
had the exact same interaction from
opposite sides
and i was like that's why i was like was
that you i don't think that was me
no i did i don't think i saw an arrow
over the head wait you're monkey tops
and bottoms right
are you pink face i've got the blue and
orange i'm on the left hand side right
behind sparkles why doesn't it have an
arrow oh no oh no oh wait oh god
you got this don't let that don't get
don't let that go
pull one over on you was that you don't
be an idiot don't be an idiot yes
good job oh oh you're in there oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh i was looking at the wrong monkey i'm
sorry
no damn i can't believe you fell just
from a simple jump that's
uh i also started in the back on the far
left if you start front middle you have
it unless you screw up
maybe maybe we will get to do the jumpy
one this time where it's like little
things spinning in the middle i don't
know how to do that one in forever oh
yeah oh
the one that always reminds me of fusion
frenzy fusion frenzy was it
which was an original xbox party game
that was basically like
someone saw mario party and was like
[ __ ] let's make like a steam punky
version of that or something and it was
like people on rollerblades
played it was all mini games it was just
mini games and it was like my favorite
xbox game as a kid it had levels that
were like the spinning one that you're
talking about
but it would get so fast where you would
be like jump duck duck jump jump jump
jump
and you were like you know you messed up
you did you did you did
oh my god i'm a god how did i do that
are you a god bouncy donuts no oh
you did oh no oh no who did that
oh yeah okay here we go i'm going for
this oh
okay i made it over one of the walls
when it was like at max height
oh you did oh yeah if you if you bounce
right off of uh another unfortunate soul
you can
sure did you can do it their face was
right in my grundle
as i laughed at them and front flipped
landed
and then the door broke their teeth uh
that's i don't think they have teeth but
i i like the visual did they add new
games yet or or is this still the same
repertoire in october
season two comes with the different
stuff they certainly have been like
tweaked okay easy peasy just don't get
slimed
get away soda can oh we're all in a
tight group here
hey friends check this [ __ ] out yeah oh
frick
oh boy oh my god you oh my god oh
shortcut accomplished anyway shortcut
not accomplished for me
oh my god who's doing that that's the
ball towards me
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh
my god on this edge
all these [ __ ] monkeys i'm the only
monkey
uh i don't think so man i think there's
many monkeys
i think there's many monkeys getting a
little full of hell oh no what am i
stuck on
yeah i got i got stuck on something too
i don't know what that was about the
floor
yeah i got stuck on a corner okay you
know normal stuff
yeah yeah totally fine there's a pirate
having sex on the
banana look out when you get up oh my
god what monkey oh
you oh my god oh you jerk
oh you suck oh my god
there's a ninja over here trying to grab
me right at the end oh
no oh hey i found wade runway
oh mark was that you that just got eated
no
i'm i died someone was on the logs
being a douche and the only consolation
is he fell in two
but someone was on the logs there's so
many pink default dudes in this one
there's also a real a-hole near the end
just trying to
prevent people from getting in
oh that's danger nah all right he all
right please die to the slime
yeah i would love for you to die to the
slime
i think that's what some people call
being the worst
it's just bm is what was that me was it
was that me just
i thought you said the other dude died
too oh yeah he did but he wasn't pink
default it was some uh i think ninja
why did it just sickly oh good soccer
this is different soccer no this is how
it'd be i've never played
it's a lot of people i've played this
before
the key is once a goal goes in the
kickoff or the ball gets dropped at the
middle and you can
one hit goals from the middle really
easily
what team are you guys we're yellow
yellow okay
i'm on the left side right now
yeah i'm trying to play defense and it's
oh god
oh no come on team why are you all
idiots
oh but we're not going to be on the
kickoff bob what uh what uh
what costume are you i've got like
boxing shorts on
okay i see i see it yeah
nice yeah good hit oh oh oh oh oh oh get
out of my life
oh boy that was not as far the the oh no
team one our team i swear to god is
self-sabotaging
they it seems like they are actually
yeah
some of the ones on our team are 100
hitting it
hitting it towards our own goal hey
there's a goal
mark oh no oh get one in you weigh holes
yeah oh oh my god uh-oh
oh is that both of you on defense there
no i'm not i'm up in the front and some
other person waits yeah weights on the
offense ball oh
i'm trying though i'm watching our team
jump the wrong way what oh yeah
oh i just saw it that was a hit that was
a hit by the yellow dude
oh no we definitely have people that are
okay
i swear to god there's like five people
working against this here
oh [ __ ] they hit it is it like the new
meme or something to try and make yellow
team lose
i guess
that idiot just fell in oh we scored one
what do you know
[Music]
what how did they do that man we were so
close the other team
kept hitting it like through me yeah
well our team kept
like they were helping the other team
too yeah but later at least
literally just like i was jumping into
the ball to hit it
and instead of going up like we both hit
it it would just go
through me and into the coal like i
didn't even exist
oh that sucks all right oh god i didn't
back out fast enough
it's a great mark who died earlier is
the only one that did well
i was like waiting for you guys all
patiently you don't need to make fun of
me too
[Laughter]
you're dumb oh guys please
dummy all right gate crash i was hoping
for this one again
what's the doordash is the one with the
break through the door right yep
doordash is a delivery service it's both
it's a delivery service that possibly
doesn't pay their employees very well
oh wait sorry they're not even employees
definitely
oh god they saved it
i love it when the door comes up and
just slaps you
oh my god i don't love that i gotta be
honest
[Music]
oh my god oh my
i saw you hit the wall right in front of
me oh
no
i didn't see it wade what happened he
didn't
jump the [ __ ] ship he slid
off the end of the ramp and face plane
at the wall
oh and i jumped over him to qualify yes
and then i actually left the group so i
came in
see ya see all right bye have a go all
right see you next time
did you rage quit wade really
accidentally
i was spamming the a button that i was
trying to show that i jumped and a
apparently decided to turn into b which
turned into leaf so i know i'm just with
my menu wait
you guys take your time have a good
round i hope you will oh
this one this is such a lame game did
you see that
the video of like someone tricking an
entire squad
to fall apparently everyone just relies
on everyone else
oh yeah i i i do sometimes but i usually
remember like four or five of them
there's like one i'm like
okay if someone goes to that one i'll
know we could do that we could be the
four people that tricked them but like
try to trick a whole bunch of people
we could do that that'd be pretty funny
uh i just saw someone very confidently
down the way
i'm i'm gambling it's gonna be grapes
oh [ __ ] oh whoa oh god
please no oh god i go
oh no i got pushed out god damn it are
we both dead
yeah oh god i didn't get out fast enough
oh hey hey guys there you go i'm good
i'm in the very back on this level
love that this is a great level what are
you what are you complaining about
oh already dead you just gotta be a
smarty
pants like me you just gotta know
physics
yeah yeah when you're in the back
physics doesn't matter when the [ __ ]
ramp is vertical
it's fine you just gotta physically oh
my god oh my god
oh my god you all right
oh no no no that's not good you're good
you're good mentally are you feeling all
right oh that's not good
oh that's not good oh this is not good
oh god
please no dude i'm not going to make it
guys guys i'm not going to be mine man
dude i hate to say this
uh no not going to make it my dudes my
guys
uh not not going to meet you guys
not going to meet you there no i'm not
gonna meet you there
guys please please guys you [ __ ]
french fries
guys uh listen remember me uh
for who i was and not for who i am right
now oh wait a minute
ah i changed my mind oh we need that
pink
why is that vertical that way that it is
oh hey friends i see you back there
oh my god why would you jump there you
clearly were not gonna make there you go
there you go go left go left go left go
left keep going keep going
left left up there you go come left come
left i'll catch you
come here wait oh my god please no
mark i see you you're not making a lot
of progress
you don't understand the things i have
endured
you don't understand what i have endured
what i've been through
what i've gone through it is yeah
it is you can do it buddy 20 or 30. oh
my god
oh my god i made it oh you're closer
you're close you're so close oh you got
this oh my god you
oh mark go the other way i'm going the
other way
you got this you got this you got this
how you should be dead
hell how did you do that you're a
goddamn wizard
i fell like five times you defied
physics like eight times
god teach me the ways senpai i don't
know
oh this one sucks whoa
get me on the orange hey mark i feel
less confident about my choice now that
i'm here
well now that we're here not to not to
judge
everything oh
hey i'm there wait am i wrong i'm wrong
[Laughter]
i was so confident oh so
confident i'm sorry were you standing by
yourself yeah i definitely would
everybody else is just idiots well i
came up with a new system i was just
like oh i'll just remember the letter
instead of like so i was like no wait no
hang on
don't laugh let that work out no i was
gonna i was going like okay
cba g you know cherry banana
apple uh cba g
oh great i was on grape cba g
w was over on the right because i was
trying to remember so i could go cba g
and i must have went left to right cba g
and then w being the extra and i was
like c b a g
w uh it's up there why not just remember
the [ __ ] fruit
what because it's fine look hey
look everyone has their own systems
what's g stand for oh no no no no it's
not that it's it's
cba g was the like the order oh my god
the numbers that i memorized it in
but the position was different so i
didn't have proper positional
alpha numerical uh comparisons
so i needed to do was cba g
and then melons and then create a grid
system
no i don't know cba g like
cba g one one two three
three one two three three four it's the
third
second if there's two threes one two
three three
it has to be by yeah i can do that yeah
by the grid system
cba gw and then o was over there so o
was outlier o stood for
outlier you know what i really think
this is gonna work man
it did we played a whole mini game in
the time it took you to explain your
system
i'm not done cba g one two three three
w four
are you like calling someone in london
or something it's c1
c1a122
e 3 g3 w4
0111 listen
my memory impeccable like some kind of
remembering machine you are yeah that's
me
uh what team you guys i'm blue blue i
think yeah we're losing
okay everyone came up here to get there
oh [ __ ] c
a b g okay so it needs some work
what i should do is i shouldn't i should
memorize
the whole grid i can memorize the whole
grid if i go in order from top to bottom
i'll know exactly what it is
it's perfect you're right i think i
think you're right sometimes are we
getting our
asses so soundly beat i bet i can come
up with a system to
remember where the rings are going to
spawn backfield center front
bcf okay and then there's like sub
sections so
b sub c sub f sub
dude we're about to lose this like b uh
there's also left and right okay b no
longer meaning
god we just got our asses kicked so bad
sub f sub c sub okay i don't know what
i'm listening to
but god isn't horrible i was calling
listen to him maybe you would have
figured out where they were
yeah i was calling him c sub b dubs
i like some chicken wings i do i was
trying to help man
oh i finally i actually got out in time
on that one oh i forgot about that
oh yeah gate crash hurts a wave at the
bottom of this one
you gotta jump yeah yeah there's a jump
hole
jumping holes oh god no you all
far fools why would everyone do that
oh god no okay just
run flip like a psychopath no go oh my
god i thought i was going to die
what oh okay yeah
get out of the way you freaking idiot
oh god oh god this is going to go
terribly there's too many people here
there's too many people people here oh
my god
oh just made it i don't know
how are you in wait wait did you make it
oh yeah yeah okay i
i keep high jumping the doors like there
are jumps i'm like i shouldn't do this
and i do it and it works and it
shouldn't man i know
i know it's probably gonna be rare we're
gonna see one of the ones we've played
before but if we get memory match again
i'll
i'll show you guys we can try your
system yeah we can try your system
definitely i kind of want to play a
memory match now
just to try this well dang it
i'm sorry how you pronounce it okay all
right let's see if i can uh
not lose my mind on this one hey you
qualified last week
really it's like a it's a center not
center positional system is what you
should be
right the numbers are more for reference
oh my god what have i done hey mark all
right
all right b1 why why
okay well there i go okay i think we
just wrote each other off into the
white wild blue yonder look at how
sideways these things these are really
sideways huh
oh oh oh oh oh god oh god oh god
no no no oh god
no no no not like this
huh interesting injury we're fine we're
fine we are surprisingly yes
fine
oh no that's not right oh please that's
all right
oh please oh goodness oh why are you
doing that to the purple one you
unbelievable monsters
no no oh oh mark people on our paddle
no i know i know i know i know all right
go go
team i'm going huh oh my god that was
close to a flunk get off me you [ __ ]
fishing pace i will kill your family
okay i'm fine did you call them a piece
of fish uh pigeon [ __ ]
oh my god what just happened to me oh
it's so vertical oh no i literally
slipped off why oh no this might be it
my dude
i don't think i'm gonna make this well
there's like a lot of people in front of
me
oh you [ __ ]
oh no mark i think i think we're done
uh yeah i don't think i'm gonna make it
my dude
all right no no no
oh do you even listen no no
like for the last 30 seconds both mark
and i were like
ah frick i don't think yeah no i i was
dead
i actually completely zoned out and
blocked you both out were you even
reading like messages or something where
you just
i looked over at chat but i wasn't even
reading chat i really just kind of
it was like a glaze went over my eyes
and i saw nothing besides that pigeon in
its neck
oh okay my system okay my system i can
do it bird's eye view
okay here we go i got you you gotta
listen to me okay you gotta listen to me
okay
when mark starts repeating it i'll say
it backwards so you have it both ways
i'm left to right he's right to left
okay a g okay
yeah a a it's a a top row is a a a
a a type a second row a g g
okay okay good good good work here in
the corner right
all right okay
good good good good good good perfect
perfect perfect okay this is the worst
bro
something cc
w
oh the system is flawless i
hate this wait you survived thank you
yeah thank him it was despite you two
talking i managed to serve we
were hell we were telling you the
answers were literally the right answers
that the universe was asking literally
the correct answers
i don't think there's any pleasing in
mark i think he's just gonna be no i'm
very thankful you guys all right i
appreciate you oh that's the spirit
all right well thank you and you're
welcome
i just needed a moment i still had all
the letters floating the numbers
circling my room it's like that it's
like that beautiful mind
meme with sandra bullock yeah all right
this one sucks good luck
yeah this is that beautiful mind game
with the balls you got this man only two
teams
you just need one to lose oh good you're
already ahead of yourself so you're fine
what team are you blue blue oh
cool you guys are good last
um no no it says they're in last but
it's part of the strat
the jump diving wait it's not working
for you it was working
stop pushing there we go there we go
that's true i don't think you should
tell them to stop why are we all
okay i guess we're switching directions
now for no good reason
oh no oh dear oh man someone's really
getting in the way up there
all right you guys are definitely we
have an actual blue in the way
you guys are definitely in some trouble
uh
where's the penguin [ __ ] i will kill um
oh my god i'm gonna murder every [ __ ]
bird i ever see
i'm a bird murderer that's my career now
who wants to hire me
i believe it's murderer look but you
have mark's system now ingrained in your
brain
it's great yeah it's right next to the
green i'm gonna feed to the [ __ ]
birds that's mixed with goddamn arsenic
he's gonna kill them all language uh
sorry i meant to say with assnic
thank you hey look doordash hey
all right guys i got a system for this
one all right
all right so obviously there's only two
doors for each one
right right they go down in numbers so
the odds of getting it
actually go up so
if you get the right guess on the first
one just keep guessing
you're lucky i'm in the back i don't
like that well actually that kind of
works for this one that's all right
i feel lucky oh they were all okay the
hell
oh yeah good job there dinosaur man okay
here we go oh yeah oh they were both
good
oh man these guys got the luck well he
doesn't even he didn't even hit the
whoops
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's fine oh my god [ __ ] the last one
left
oh no oh my gosh get up
way behind you guys
dead last i think you guys
it don't worry all right cool yeah hey
man
so funny because the door pieces were
like jammed in with everyone
you guys got through and the door pieces
shot
backwards and just pulled this over like
here in the
bowl this all over like all of us went
like just like bowling
let's play soccer i love it i'll get you
i got you the system
i got you the system okay what's the egg
system marketing scramble
okay so listen it's a numbers game right
how many eggs are there
there are 28 eggs we're red we're red
just so you know
okay okay there you are good one
good bob you're following the system
that's good yeah i'm following i'm
following my heart
dude oh that's a smart strategy
someone's got a gold egg in there
they're just holding it
that's smart to attract all the
attention no they're in the the goals
yeah yeah in your own in your own thing
in your own like area whole
multiple egg yeah that's good and that's
a good point
yellow is losing bad oh nope scores are
changing all of that because all of
oh no you got it you got it
yeah good defense oh i got
don't grab me there we go there we go
throw it throw it there we go grab it
secure it
oh that's you sorry wade you're good
you're trying to escape
no no no oh yeah you got it you got it i
see that yeah you got it
damn it yeah you guys are my golden yeah
your gold egg yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's good man that's good good
strategy good strategy yeah let him have
all the pleb eggs
who cares this one is worth so much
pointage
how many points is like five i think
it's five oh yeah that's definitely
worth it
why aren't they coming after me i don't
understand i think they're trying to do
but they keep going oh no
oh that's a bad thing i was your own
touchdown that was your own tv
oh why oh no we're good we're good we're
good yeah yeah you're good you got it
yeah you're gonna
get off me monkey you got it was that
you wade
what no i'm in the yellow thing i'm in
yellow's base
monkey was on me while i was playing
these little monkeys
being a monkey was a mistake monkeys and
birds can
suck my dick i thought they were mortal
enemies yeah you'd think that
but no it turns out they're working
together and i got to change my skin for
this match
okay i'll answer i gotta join mark i'm
gonna be naked naked is the only way
yeah i that's what i've been saying this
whole time oh cool shoot
okay oh a-a-b-o i'll call out letters
you'll know that
that fruit is coming your way okay all
right thank you
left to right or right to left or front
to back it's gonna go uh left to right
center or middle where should we run
okay left is one
center is two right is three okay okay
so we have to go to the a2 w3 be
to a one holy spirit
why am i doing it w 2 w 3 b 1
a 3 oh no that's not what i thought was
going to happen
w 1 a youtube
okay you're fine you're fine you're
clear you're clear oh
and clear bobby you're clear i'm gonna
make it too
no did you make it wade
no oh god all right this time we got it
also this is my last one but this is it
i forgot to change my skin oh god you're
right i'm still a traitorous monkey oh
no well that's why i don't have any luck
today no luck cause i'm a terrible
monkey
hey the same one again oh right at least
it's a good one i guess i don't know
what i'm complaining about
you remember when there were like six
other maps we haven't seen
what no that ain't real oh i must have
been dreaming
uh front and center baby if you
lose you're an idiot
well i mean oh my god
oh it didn't work this time mark that
thing you said to happen
wow uh sorry about that man i should
have used the
the numbering system i was a fool
no wait get out of me
oh god i laid on my ass for too long oh
god oh god bad timing bad timing oh
frick wait you just bounced over me you
dick i did
oh yeah you like used my face as a
launch pad to get into the
area sorry did you like my feet
no did you make it in your feet yeah i'm
in
okay good i was number one actually i
was literally number one
as you should have been oh man oh i
don't i know it's
probably not gonna happen but if we get
fruit match again
yes yes yes what are the odds
yes okay i'm gonna show you guys this is
going to be all right mark i'm just
going to fall i'm not even going to look
at anything i'm going to listen to you
okay good
do you want me to say it out loud i can
i can say it out loud if you're yeah say
it out loud
and proud okay a okay a a
a b a b b the second
make sure you're on b b my dudes
got some white douche bag over here
being grabby
okay it's easy
w b b w yeah yeah yeah b o c o
oh
honestly like i'm going to screw up here
just because
all right okay
a b o w g c
a
oh my god no one joined me so i thought
i was wrong
[Laughter]
but the system works he has two people
it doesn't work
oh god i'm so confused oh
you know what honest to god that helped
that was way easier than trying to
remember the fruits
let's see that that was like the point
that i was trying to get across but
saying when multiple people are
memorizing multiple different lines
saying different letters out loud for
different sections
that did not help hi we all made it for
the first time
it was like banana orange oh b b-o-b-b
i don't even know what i'm on anymore oh
hell yeah this one's scary now this one
is scary now
so many gaps and whatnot hey friend
there's the pigeon
the pigeon hate the pigeon really likes
me gap why
wall oh mark oh i'm fine look
i'm right next to you i'm just nervous
because we're in a dangerous zone
hey wade how's it going well you didn't
tell me you had a grabby [ __ ] over here
everyone likes grabbing the monkey
everyone likes grabbing the monkey well
you're the one who's an annoying [ __ ]
yeah why did you
choose to be the monkey monkey but
everyone wants to grab me
no everyone knows that the monkeys are
the a-holes look at everyone touching
the monkey
yeah that's what the kids do that's what
they call it
are you a wheel on the prices right
you know when you're making noises like
that it makes you seem like you want
people
to grab you no i do not monkeys are like
hey
oh my god you smell bad okay why is
everyone so rude to the monkey
well maybe because you stink you think
we're telling lies over here you should
maybe you should consider your own why
is everyone chasing me
i don't like that i don't like that at
all there's a whole crowd of people
coming this way
oh pink person i'm not trying to mess
with you i'm just going this direction
okay i am not staring at you oh oh i'm
going down down wait
sounds like you were still a whole mark
you were all very very
bumped me into the oblivion it's quite
fast all of a sudden
oh only one more needs to fall who's it
going to be
oh
mark i was going to push you in if we
didn't end that soon why wait
no why because i think i can because i
think you
stink okay well rude all right
good job guys yeah hey we we made pretty
fast
things i regret do you though oh
i've never gotten to play this one oh
this one's fun
mark you know you win this one well how
the strat on this one is hugging your
friends that no wait hang on i don't
like that strat
yeah no it's super effective all you
have to do is find your friends
and give them a big hug i don't
all right you know what fine all right
you know what no no we'll hug let's go
okay let's hug let's hug let's hug let's
hug oh my god this hug is so stressful
the most stressful hug it's like a trust
fall
you gotta find your friend your trust
fall guys
interesting interesting new territory uh
yeah no okay so we have to hog between
the jumps but not during the job
yeah come here mark okay and then jump
you almost threw me but that's
interesting come here mark
your friends
i blame that one on you i'm pretty sure
that's your fault get rid of the pigeons
oh my god mark what are you doing no
people if people grab you and you try to
jump
sacred oh my god
oh mark oh yes oh my god oh my god you
little [ __ ] oh my god oh what the hell
i wouldn't get on i would not get up
it wouldn't get back up did you both die
no i'm alive oh okay i just couldn't
work out
what was that mark you really let me
down
i'll carry one for the team here what
this is something horrible then i'll
just
die
the last one this is it this is for all
the the mobile the mobile marbles
mobile game marbles
don't if you don't touch the pigeon oh
that's not good
wait did you notice what happened yeah
it sure did that's new that's new that's
new to me
oh oh no that's happened before that
happens before
i've not seen that happen before on the
normal one well they couldn't possibly
take away my blue one again
hey hey all right
um okay maybe i should move inland a
little bit instead of living life on the
edge all the time
nah you might as well live on the coast
oh wait what have you done
wait wait wait i can't oh my god
oh come on you'll have a good time
the fact i'm you [ __ ] horse
wait gotta you gotta jump over it man
wait you got a hole man oh
this is about to get deathy all the
pigeons down
kill the pigeon the horse is done yes
kill them
who are you instructing to kill them no
i want the the
karma god i don't care at this point the
lag is making it seem like you get hit
by him
every time yeah the lag is wild it's
like you're just scooching over it
oh that's a good one yay
oh this is a problem not a problem for
you
come on baby come on can i call me baby
are you calling yourself baby in this
situation if i can
hold yourself baby
oh the leg is making this really
confusing to spectate no no but it's so
nice
i swear i pressed the jump my jump
button doesn't always work
not like tyler the loser okay honestly
don't care oh that dude's
dead holy [ __ ] the pigeon is rotting in
hell next to its
horse [ __ ] counterpart language is
that a
pigeon's spouse that also has sex with
horses or
i don't know yeah sure oh my god the
dude with the egg hat he's gonna win
uh nice job egg hat i like apple egg hat
you have my respect
all right well done i was a good monkey
no not really but
man sure whatever you think man whatever
you think
i'll go back to being a tactical oh yuck
why is that color what even already
happened
oh throw at the cactical i hate i hate
it all right i'm
i i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna leave i'm
gonna leave now don't leave
i'm leaving i am leaving